horror en el país Vasco francés un
alumno de 16 años apuñaló mortalmente a
su profesora de español fue en el
colegio Santa madacan en San Juan de luz
y así lo narró una compañera
Estaba en clase de español todo iba
normal hasta que un alumno se levantó y
apuñaló a la profesora de español en el
pecho con un cuchillo grande cuando
levanté la vista ya estaba de pie con el
cuchillo
hasta el lugar acudió el ministro de
Educación
dijo que era un trauma para Francia
nadie podía prever un hecho tan horrendo
tanto el director como los profesores me
dijeron que este establecimiento era muy
tranquilo conocido por su seriedad así
como la de su ambiente educativo
el adolescente declaró a la policía
haber escuchado voces y el gobierno
anunció Un minuto de silencio el jueves
en todas las escuelas a las 3 de la
tarde el presidente Manuel se pronuncia
en Twitter el asesinato de una maestra
en San Juan de luz nos llena de intensa
emoción Comparto el dolor de su familia
sus compañeros sus alumnos y nuestros
maestros que dedican su vida a
transmitir conocimientos a las futuras
generaciones la nación está de su lado
el 16 de octubre de 2020 fue el último
precedente del asesinato de un profesor
en Francia fue Samuel para ti decapitado
por un islamista checheno de 18 años
esto generó una gran conmoción y un
funeral de estado